very popular place for families now
dealing with vandalism staff at
gilchrist orchard in the northwest part
of the valley hoping the community can
help find those responsible madison
kimbrough visiting the area today and
she joins us in studio with more
people from all over love going to this
popular family destination spot but
saturday night someone decided to leave
a lasting impression and now the orchard
is thousands of dollars in the hole
because of it
we had a couple kids come in here they
rammed the fence with the car
and then
went
looking for things to do and
found a couple golf carts driving them
around and then rammed the fence on
going out with one of our golf carts
operational director mark rubin of
gilchrist orchard describing what
happened saturday night as kids were
caught on camera trespassing on their
property and unfortunately this isn't
the first time as cars have rammed into
their fencing before as speeding is one
of the top issues along whispering sands
drive on the northwest side of town it's
just sad that
it was needless expenditure this is an
expensive fence to repair if anybody has
any ideas who these
two are let us know and neighbors say
living near the orchard is one of their
favorite aspects to living in the area
so for people to disrespect it is
disheartening it is
kind of offsetting that
they know somebody around here would do
that i'm assuming they live in probably
in the neighborhood also
but
just to do it just out of spite or for
whatever reason they did it just doesn't
doesn't
seem right as for the damage ruben
predicts the cost to be up to two
thousand dollars that's to replace the
fencing and the vandalized golf carts
but the orchard has already been in
talks with metro and a police report
will soon be filed
and the orchard is offering a reward to
anyone who helps find those two people
you saw in the video back to you